started thank you all for coming it's
good to see that the fact that it's
raining and that this is in a different
building and then it's between terms
this is a nice nice turnout and so we're
all here today too for the thesis
proposal defense of dr. ben sanders who
is one of our national library medicine
postdoc fellows and who's in the master
of science program so the process for
that is that when people are ready to
defend whether it's a master's thesis or
PhD dissertation they present to the
department and also to their committee
and attendance CRMs at that moment are
so they get feedback and can proceed on
to complete their work and will
hopefully come back anywhere from 6 12
24 etcetera months depending whether
it's masters or PhD and then defend
their proposal hopefully successfully
that will enable them to graduate so dr.
Sanders is a graduate of the youth UNC
Chapel Hill School of Medicine in 2004
he also earned an mph degree and then
did a residency in pediatrics in
University of Rochester he had a few
positions along the way and also while
continuing to work as a primary care
pediatrician in 2018 so a little over a
year ago he joined our program as a
postdoc fellow and he also has some
responsibilities in the department of
pediatrics and his overall goal is to
improve pediatric primary care using
informatics
and especially in the screening referral
evaluation and treatment of
developmental disabilities including
autism so he will present his oh and his
committees here Katie
Joan all and he will present his
proposal leaving some time for questions
for us to ask him further details and
even potentially make suggestions in his
project so over you thank you very much
[Applause]
this rider testing testing testing
testing really it's it's mainly for the
recording and we're broadcasting okay
great thank you guys for coming
really appreciate your show interest by
participating today so I would like to
talk to you guys about the informatics
of early intervention and pearls this is
my master's thesis proposal so I won't
have tons of cool results for you but
but there's a lot to talk about this is
a type of study would call it a national
nested mixed methods study so first
let's talk about what is early interment
so I'm gonna clear up this is a painting
for my painted by my father who's back
here back of our first child sky and we
call this first steps and and I think
it's very appropriate for this because
it's in the home and and the the family
context is critical but early
intervention for children who may not
walk as early as sky did it's really
nice to have my family to be a part of
this thank you guys
children with developmental disabilities
are eligible for programming
government programming that is offers
things like speech therapy physical
therapy and it's it's paid for by tax
dollars and what's really special about
early intervention is the evidence that
it really works on the literature over
over time different settings different
populations and different time spans of
study it's been shown to not only work
quite well but pay for itself as many as
six times over and also the word early
is critical here the earlier you do it
the better of an effect it has this is
child brain plasticity and actually this
is their much more receive the effects
of an intervention much better earlier
on so let's take a look at the sort of
the pipeline how do children move into
inter early activity so many of them
will interact hopefully most of them
will enter all of them will interact
with their provider in the health care
setting or it might be in preschool that
they would be identified and hopefully
most of them screened although we know
that not all children receive a
validated screening questionnaire and
then of those some of them will be
determined to be not at risk and some
will be determined to be at risk and not
all of them will be referred for lots of
different reasons and some of them get
referred directly without screening and
then from there starts the referral
process and it does not always get
completed but for those what I mean by
completion of referral is did they get
evaluated by the early intervention
staff to determine whether they're
eligible for services and then from
there we have other children who
completed their evaluation some of them
may not have completed it but of the
ones who completed it somewhat qualify
for services some didn't qualify and
there's this middle category in some
states where you could be a separate
program where you could be monitored and
what I'm interested in and what as
you'll see is the referral process but
this area of the of the chart here are
is the population of children that is
food that I want to affect these are
kids who most likely would benefit from
early intervention and habit so this is
a pretty big problem here's the
population wide data so if you estimate
about 13 percent of children at any one
time from 0 to 3 are developmentally
delayed that comes out to 1.2 million
children in the United States two-thirds
of them is 800,000 and they do not
receive early intervention here is we
don't have national data for this and
that but that's a really critical part
of my pieces but this is a study that
studied a cohort of children and
basically it's from how well did some
EHR decision support affect this
pipeline in done in Philadelphia and you
can see here with the three different
study arms all of them had significant
drops in a number of children as they
went from in the clinic today the delay
identified to not all of them being
referred to not all the referred
children actually completing evaluation
now in comparison to the previous
pipeline diagram I showed you this is a
this is really focusing in on the
referral portion of it the the screening
would come beforehand and you lose some
children in that part of the process and
then you know whether or not a family
actually attended services to which they
are eligible would also be a part of
that pipeline and a part of this this
number so this 800 million children is
sort of an aggregation of all of the
stats
so it's not only a sizeable problem but
it's it's a it's a morally reprehensible
problem our society's most vulnerable
children our studies have shown they're
the ones who respond the best respond
the most may benefit the most from early
intervention and they're actually the
least likely to receive services not
just a few studies show this so I think
we can do better
I think service integrated services
integration inclusion data integration
is an important part of solutions for
improvement here and just for humor this
is a war a cape on the day that we went
live from paper to next year in 2011 so
somehow somebody for some reason had a
cape that said supervinlin says okay so
back to the pipeline here are the steps
that we talked about and I want to point
out a pattern here the website of
portion most of this occurs in the
health care setting and on the right
side most of this and most states occur
within the educational setting or sector
so that makes this transfer even more
important than some of the others in
this diagram in my view it's a cross
sector transition so let's take a closer
look at that transition including let's
ask ourselves let me talk to you about
why early intervention referrals are
often not completed briefly the referral
is made the parent might call themselves
or in many cases most cases a physician
would make a decision with the parent
they would decide together this is what
they should do is is see if early
intervention would be the child would be
eligible and that information might get
sent often by fax sometimes they
in some cases even electronic the intake
coordinator at the early intervention
agency would coordinate this initial
evaluation often done in the home it's
sometimes done at a local early
intervention center and the referral
might not the evaluation might not
actually get completed and so in that
sense the referral would not have the
intended effect and if it is the child
as you saw in the diagram it would be
the child would be eligible or
ineligible or maybe qualify for this
middle monitoring list this is the
reasons for not working so well are
quite complex we don't I don't want to
focus on the details I'm going to
present a number of them but my main
point being that there's complexity and
there's a few important portions of it
so we're going to look at five different
sections so family and cultural factors
is really important we have evidence
population wide and qualitative evidence
to illustrate how families that have
less education who are living in poverty
and less literacy have much less ability
to advocate for their child which is
turns out to be necessary unfortunately
if you're a single parent you're less
likely to have a successful referral if
you are black or any other sort of group
that is underrepresented you would also
be less likely to receive services or I
have a say a successful referral so and
then on the community level this can
look like things like lack of safety we
actually have studies to show us that
their direct effects on things like
executive function of a family or the
health of a child at the neighborhood's
not
and right along with that things like
resources security housing and stability
those can kind of add up to create a
sort of a chaos and disorganization that
are really get in the way of
participating in a referral there's also
a poor understanding of early
intervention and even child development
on the part of referral sources
including pediatricians that some even
have a more pessimistic view that if
they refer their patient the patient
actually might not benefit either not
get services or or get services they
were not helpful and then on a systems
level we have siloed agencies and so
that means siloed data it also means
it's difficult for a family to navigate
between those and it's difficult for
other folks who want to know what
happened to communicate with all the
different players just like public
education but we're so early
intervention is chronically underfunded
it's pretty famous for that true across
the country
and I think part of that is probably
because there's there's not a lot of
folks know what early intervention is or
really understand child development well
enough to for it to inform policy say a
policymaker or a voter but that affects
the the family's understanding also and
then when you get down to the folks who
actually deliver these services they
have high caseloads they have lower
salaries than they could get if they
were to work here oh and kiss you for
example and there's a lot of burnout in
turnover so let's keep down to more
specifics here with informatics I want
to start with a quote as the
pediatrician I spoke to last year I
would like a closed loop communication
system with early intervention often we
don't get feedback about our referrals
if there was a miscommunication or other
problem and may not find out until say
six months later when they come in again
unless the family is concerned and calls
me I can't remember getting a report
from early intervention about a referral
as
it was brought in to me by parents this
is quite common so what approaches and
what things does health informatics have
to offer to this problem I think we can
agree computers are an essential tool
boy forward not just in healthcare but
keeping track with any data but human
communication is really the core
activity that we're talking about here
with a referral and I think in
fermentations are good at not forgetting
the human component of this also the the
data is fragmented as we mentioned and I
think informatics is used to dealing
with fragmentation with it's a
multidisciplinary approach and dealing
with cross sector problems this is a
complicated problem and it's also hard
to know whether you know whether
something worked in that complex
environment and I think health
informatics has a track record of
dealing with those problems also with
frameworks so what parts of this can
informatics affect well this may be the
more obvious one that you could see I'm
headed towards is that if you were to
integrate data between the institutions
they would be less disconnected it would
be easier for you to sit in your one
agency say the clinic and be able to
find out easily through the computer
what happened with your child's referral
however you're not going to the data
integration is not going to affect
housing instability and you know high
caseloads so so what are some other
directions I think a more proximal sort
of direct effect it can have is enabling
something like tracking referrals this
is becoming a bigger priority and part
of the order
government as we got we've gotten better
at screening and now it's time to truly
figure out what happened with our kids
as we refer them but tracking there's
some evidence to show that that clinics
have been able to generate a tracking
program have had much higher rates of
referral completion and then I think
probably the most important effect here
that informatics solutions such as data
integration and I'll get more specific
later is is an indirect effect that
really sort of enables other activities
so if the data is integrated then all of
a sudden you can answer questions like
how many children were referred we don't
have that data now you can't say
nationally or even though the state
level in many cases how many children
were even referred to begin with and
then how many of those referrals were
successful you can't answer that and you
would be able to answer that type of
question with data integration and so I
think that there would be a ground-up
effect from interventions like this
another level of the fact would be for
example being able to evaluate a program
or an intervention designed to improve
referral rates or other parts of the
pipeline you'd be able to answer the
question well did it work you can't do
that now
okay for my research I think that you
know making solutions is all fine and
good but it's hard to know what to solve
with such a complex problem and it's
hard to sometimes it's a mistake to even
assume you can come up with the right
solution without doing your background
research so for my thesis I'm doing sort
of a start of a career trajectory
hopefully to start with describing what
actually occurred so more specifically
what data is sent who sends it and who
receives it how is it said what other
important communication occurs in this
process not just the stuff that's on
paper or not just the official
information and then what quality you
know how can we track the quality of
this process are they are these
referrals effective are they timely
family centered
are they efficient are they equitable I
think we can assume they're safe so I'm
only about that sixth quality and then
to go along with that what are some
barriers what are what are the barriers
around that okay so let's go back to our
model for a minute I want to show you a
little bit about data that we actually
do have around first let's go to URLs
sources I have some Corrigan data for
that the primary sources of early
intervention referrals in Oregon is from
the healthcare setting a distant second
is parents and family and there's a
smattering of other agencies and sectors
that contribute so back to the model
again to it for reference
who what is the agency there's variation
between states about which agency
actually delivers the program of early
intervention so we do have some national
data on this this pie
that gives you the number by these are
the number of states including DC and
Puerto Rico that's why it'll add up to
52 that means a certain type of agency
to deliver early intervention so the
largest group 18 states deliver early
intervention within their health
agencies so that would be defined as an
agency that actually delivers health
care such as a public health clinic or a
state-funded se HIV treatment program
that kind of agency is majority of the
cases education including like
kindergarten through twelfth grade that
sort of part of the state government
would be the case that they deliver
early intervention in 12 states Human
Services which is things like it could
include public health like the
inspectors of the restaurants and
disease surveillance and things like
that not directly health care would be
this other category and then some of the
smaller ones for example there are a few
states that have agencies that are a
little more focused on early learning or
disabilities so that's some national day
that about that part let's look for a
minute at what proportion of children
actually receive early intervention
services and I should qualify here I
should have done at the beginning that
these are not exact proportions these
are this graph is is not to scale
so who how many children do states
enroll this is a histogram and and it's
so so the rough proportion of children
that have developmental delays is around
13% so you can see the ten here so so if
children zero to three years of age
there's about this many children the
census population on average and these
are the actual averages of the
individual states in terms of how what
proportion of children they actually
treat with early intervention so
everywhere from some states have as
little as point eight percent of their
children zero to three are enrolled in
early intervention and on up to as high
as 10% with sort of a prevalence right
around two and a half percent so where
are these states what does this look
like we could look at the upper and
lower 20% just for for an example
there's a pretty heterogeneous
distribution except there's some
clustering around the Northeast for the
upper proportions of enrollment and some
clustering around the southeast and the
lower but we also have evidence about
what what are some of the determinants
of enrollment rate so the states
individual states have the leeway to
define what they mean by a developmental
delay it could be very narrow or they
could include they could have a sort of
a liberal definition and how wide or
narrow their definition is affects the
amount of enrollment quite a bit so a
state with narrow criteria
a child living in that state at 0 3
would be 70% less likely to be enrolled
which agency
the state uses to deliver the early
intervention has an effect health
agencies tend to do better and then
there's the at-risk criteria you can
some children receive services because
they are at risk of having developmental
delay even if they haven't had one
documented yet and so from the states
that do that you also increase
enrollment interestingly the where the
referral comes from appears to be a
neutral factor on the rates of
enrollment and I think that what that
tells us is more that the way we do
things now no matter where the
enrollment comes from is not working
very well not that referrals are not
worth the focusing on and then let's
look at some demographic factors so
poverty has a really strong effect so as
a proxy for poverty of being on public
insurance you're less likely to be
enrolled you're also less likely to be
to get evaluated on time if if you're
poor and this would make sense children
with more severe delays that can
identify earlier they get more likely to
be enrolled in services this communities
of color english-as-a-second-language
communities in poverty
these folks are consistently under
enrolled across many studies many states
and so there's quite a disparity there
again interestingly the fact that the
rates of physician screening in a state
don't seem to have a big effect on
enrollment so if we were to study this
and get more information from an
informatics lens where would we start
so these are the the main people who are
served directly involved in early
intervention referrals the table gets
referred and their family the early
intervention staff who receive the
referral the referral sources and then
government as in the state agency that
delivers it or the federal
a government that does a lot of the
funding and there were my thesis from
focusing on one of these sectors the
contact information for government
agencies across the nation is easily
available and getting in contact with
national representative sample of family
medicine providers and pediatricians is
much more difficult so here are my
research goals and aims as you saw
before
that's operationalize this so first
I'm collecting and studying early
intervention referral forms most of its
much of it is done by fax and provides a
thing to sample and that will address
some parts of these goals and aims as
you see here then a survey of early
intervention leadership I'm going to
invite representatives from all 50
states and mainly getting at this first
bullet point in the aims there and then
what I would call it an explanatory
qualitative interview with respondents
who respond so and that we'll get to
some of the why of the of the data and
then these findings will inform
development of the study design for
future phases okay go back to the first
approach let's take a look at some of
the forms so I've done if you saw my
poster this year this is some of the
work that I presented then it's an
example of the American Academy of
Pediatrics standardized form and here's
a sort of way you can kind of divide up
the data in different categories and as
I was saying before I think this is a
really good a convenient way to study
this type of interaction at least as it
exists now I have collected eight film
so far from seven different states and
I found 146 unique fields in these six
categories but it turns out that all of
the forms together only 62 of those
fields really encompass all let's say
80% of all the data fields on the
columns so if we were to look at an
example of that here's three different
example categories the demographics
reason for referral and release of
information this these would be the
categories most often user at least in
the up upper 8 percent of cases across
that sample geyser park and on the other
side it this is just you can see a
little bit about the distribution of
number of fields for the different
categories so this has made a brief
example of the starting the process of
examining these referral forms and these
will the results for this will inform
the later phases especially in some of
the potential solutions ok let's go to
the survey 50 states and the District of
Columbia there's survey so their contact
information is available through their
early childhood technical assistance
center we have Qualtrics here even I can
administer the survey on as a platform
and if getting poor response I can
resort to snail mail and I'll be doing
reminders by phone and email my goal
response rate is 45 questionnaires I'd
like to represent approximately 60% of
states with an average of one and a half
questionnaires per state there might be
more than one per state because I'm
going to when I reach out to these
contacts and ask them who would be the
best person to answer some of these
questions because some of them are a
little more technical and so I may get
more than one informant for each state
but regardless I'm going to focus on
representing these different these four
variables it's important I think to
represent the range of different lead
agencies across the states there are
range of the
ability criteria the range of racial and
ethnic diversity represented by the
states that I sample and then the actual
referral methods a few states do have
electronic referrals in place and I
would want to make sure that that was in
the sample for example or would say
website the certainly now as it stands
has twenty questions there's twelve
multiple-choice rating or estimated
percentile type questions I'll give you
some examples there's a comment section
some sort answer and the questions at
the end ask if they're willing to
participate in interviews here's an
example about referral sources who send
referrals to early intervention most
often in yourself this is this
questionnaire is still a draft but this
is a this is kind of example where I'm
headed
I try to combine the question of who
sends it with sort of the proportions
and hopefully that will be an achievable
they can kind of rank these in a way
that we get a hundred percent so we can
get an idea and then there's another one
what message for sending referrals are
available in your state and I think I
still have some work to do on some of
these some of these options to simplify
them but it's an example of kind of what
I'm trying to get at and then so a
little bit of follow-up about what
referral forms they use I mean it's it
may be difficult to capture some of the
variation with instance that some states
have a number of different forms that
are used in separate regions within the
state so and they modify this question
but I think it's important to ask it and
then how much does that referral form
used and then
so after that for the folks who are
willing to talk with me this is this
would not be exploratory qualitative
research that would be more of the sort
of the contrast of towards the
explanatory I'm kind of already imposing
a structure on this in terms of wanting
to improve referrals with those quality
aides and really I want kind of the y22
the what but it really it is a
qualitative conversation that needs to
be had I can't really do it with a
survey so I want to further explore
these perspectives from the state
leaders where some of the interview
guide questions will be coming from I'm
going to pilot the interview guide with
the with Oregon State earlier
intervention leadership these will be
done by telephone and transcribed if I'm
traveling to meet with family in home in
North Carolina I'm going to do that one
in person and so no the transcripts but
memos that I write as I'm doing the
interview about our conversation will be
incorporated into this and state
websites and then if there are other
documents that they have available like
data definitions or or policies around
this I would collect and include and
then and then codebook development I
don't have a big qualitative research
team which would be ideal but I think
from my education I think it's critical
to get multiple investigators input on
doing things like developing the
codebook and and then also reviewing
some of the analysis and this is
time-consuming so I'm hoping to get
representation from these different
aspects of early intervention referrals
between
with as little as six to ten well as a
little representation from as well as
six to ten states and potentially more
than one per state but I think time may
ultimately define the limit for that so
I would want to know from them you know
here's what you put it or here's what
your colleagues put on these on the
survey that you filled out but can you
tell me more about that I don't want to
know things like what do you what do you
think about how the state of things are
now do you think that it works well do
you think that it happens in a timely
fashion our family's involved in this
process or is there if there any sort of
state-level
prioritization of families centeredness
or disparity and addressing disparities
okay and then lastly the the you know
I'm going to incorporate this into the
next phases which include talking to
some of the other other sources but in
terms of the analysis of the courses we
just went over we have the referral
forms here I'll have some descriptive
analysis of the survey data but we'll
need to use some qualitative techniques
from the open-ended questions and I'm
going to develop a a priori process for
reconciling questionnaires within a
state that are descriptive it might be
as simple as calling up the respondents
and saying you disagreed with the other
person what do you really think and then
they what we're doing what we're doing
here is is sort of describing the
phenomenon of referrals and and that's
the that that would be the type of
qualitative analysis and so it's not
inductive some so much as deductive and
then
to summarize the information this would
be sort of the academic product here
this last point for the near term but
all along and I need to be considering
the informatics implications so what did
it you know answering questions like
what are the what is the current state
of up data what is the world what are
the roles of current referral methods
and what are their other parts types of
information transfer that are critical
to this process that if we miss we're
going to create unreasonable solutions
and then I am anticipating that
potential solutions down the road are
going to need to address some of these
challenges there's a lot of variation
between states and even within states
there's not a lot of money to do this
type of stuff the the different parties
involved in actually doing the referral
have different agendas and you know the
families and their preferences really
need to be kept a high priority and then
later I want to get the perspectives of
other stakeholders families providers
referral coordinators and as I go and
integrate these phases together so that
eventually I hope to be able to propose
data structures functions and formats
needed to make early intervention
referrals better that is outside of the
scope of this year but speaking of this
year here's the there's a timeline tried
to simplify I don't know if you can read
this here's here are the weeks left in
the academic year here - this is the
time I have left
here's IRB the survey duration here's
fall term interviews analysis through
here manuscript writing preparation for
defense
and submission of a manuscript to
journal one than the thesis defense and
then on the greater scale this is just
sort of a guess about how it might do
this
so here the other stakeholders and
participants in the referral process and
I would reuse some of the methods but
then or for these other populations and
overlap some of these analyses and over
time generate a framework using all the
information that's what I got I want to
thank dr. Paul Warwick dr. Katie
Zeppelin Joe Nash for your contributions
and support to me your specific faculty
the ability contributed that I
appreciate D my staff colleagues have
made specific contributions other
colleagues outside of D mice here and
some folks outside of the witch's you
and especially my family and my partner
dog here who has put quite a bit of
investment in am I being able to
generate this work and and do my best
I'm funded by the National Library of
Medicine that's it
don't plan to look at cost or cost
effectiveness or maybe the different
states or compartments have different
approaches that are maybe some more
coffee than other is like is somehow
more pelling help approaches the problem
I suppose the individual therapies
you're saying of the state's approach to
delivering to receiving referrals you're
not are you talking about the whole
system or yes yes I guess I'm looking at
more of the state of what their programs
are but that is that outside of your
scope it's outside the scope but also we
have some data about that not excellent
data but we have you can make a pretty
good argument that it's that overall it
says this is worth doing well because it
is very cost effective yes so it was
really easy to cover I'm just interested
in so with your explanatory qualitative
phase yeah house communication was there
between pediatricians and supporters why
these referrals kind of like fall flat
because it seems like that would be
another perspective that could be useful
so I won't be getting down to the sort
of clinical level in this phase
unfortunately I really had hoped to it
came down to access to populations and I
really it was really important for me to
get a national sample and so so as I
look at referral sources I'm definitely
gonna have the approach of for the team
of care and and so we'll probably hit on
some of the issues like the different
roles not just the physician
thank you you made a point at the end
about the kind of between states and
within states kind of interactions and
women chose which states you were going
to look at you know for your national
level how much do you think there is a
lot of crosswalk between the states like
you know the northern border of Oregon
and
seven murder of Washington's or says
some of this you know where you might
work in Wednesday but live in another
state or your caregivers you know where
you are dealing with kind of multiple
states in your negotiation potentially
whereas maybe some of the other states
your model a there really aren't that
many kind of border populations you know
as it was you know you get a smooth both
kinds of situations based on where
you've chosen your state samples I I yes
and no so on the ground it turns out
that this the families that end up
having to deal with those types of
things because the the delivery of these
services is is based on state
organization policies and things like
that so so when they actually get to the
right place it would really be specific
to it's based on their where they live
so that would be fairly clear from a
sort of governmental systems perspective
but unfortunately you know we can't
ignore the fragmentation and so families
living in such a scenario absolutely
would have difficulty with that and so
maybe in further phases that would be
part of the the picture is how to
navigate just where the heck do I go
does that address your yeah the thing is
I just meant like in your states like in
the states you chose are there states
where they're more like lots of people
are in the tri-state area living
differently than like their providers in
you know New York City but they live in
New Jersey but they're you know or the
Washington Oregon thing like do you have
samples of kind of both kind of states
where a lot of people are crossing
border lots of state scenario person
some states where it's really just like
that states mostly dealing with bats
right yeah right yeah I'm sure if I had
that level of information there probably
would be clustering of effects and
things like that based on more
population kind of economic centers
instead of governmental structures but
I've kind of committed to a more limited
sampling method by by going to the state
government at least at this phase now
that makes sense I think I was just
trying to picture where your states were
on the map
the questionnaire is gonna go out to all
50 states in DC and and which ones I get
back it's the first answer and then of
those the ones that are willing to do
interviews would be the answer for the
phase after that perfect that's what I
was trying to understand for you simply
intentionally or is it first yeah so
it's it is a combination so I'm glad you
bring that up is that you know I'm gonna
see who who I get responses back and the
people that I will pursue the hardest
will be the ones that that represent the
sections that I really would want to
have represented okay thank you for your
question two questions one if you had to
go off a hunch right now what's your
hypothesis for what your results might
be can you describe the down comparing
what do you think would be the top one
or two barriers that come out of this
funding and variation so so I think
state organic or organization agency
leaders are gonna say we don't have
money for anything we can't even pay our
folks to keep them here long enough I
just got here last month because last
person could I think that's going to be
one of the major themes and then and and
and sort of the profundity of effects
that has on institutions getting
anything done and then a variation
because in some states California for
example
really they're quite regional the
regional centers that deliver early care
actually have most of the
decision-making power at how things are
done and it would be really hard to say
much that that's very useful about a
whole state and I think that'll make it
difficult but but in terms you could
call that a result also is that the
variation is so prevalent that it's it's
difficult to to talk about the second
question is let's say serve any
responses come back and you did fine
what did you do at that point because
your third method and realized along
that second what's wondering what kind
of pivot might you be able to do to
still get good results or actionable
results if the survey doesn't get quite
the response you want even with the
follow-up phone calls
okay so sort of like even beyond putting
the phones renewed for copper mines yeah
yeah I will probably emphasize the
referral forms and and the inferences I
can make from that because I think it is
that's a I I think I can go a good ways
and making some conclusions about what's
happening but that's that is absolutely
possible I don't think I've planned for
that at this point so what kinds of
people around the mailing list I'm
trying to get a picture of the
organization's do they have information
on the servers or who do you think will
be answering the question I do hope to
get access to some of the folks who
manage data in these states and this in
this day and age most states have some
even if it's just one person if somebody
that deals with the data some organs is
there's a good bit more complex and has
decades of experience but but most
states have somebody that at least you
know owns the excel file in their
computer that can talk about this data
so I hope to get to a person like like
that and then to to leader that has some
experience with what happens on the
ground maybe somebody that that would be
a referral intake coordinator that kind
of rose to the rank but in terms of
their official title or the titles of
the agencies that's really gonna vary
quite a bit and so it's at least through
federal funding and federal requirements
there are some standardizations of roles
so there has to be a designated contact
person there has to be an early
intervention lead agency that's sort of
a federal term lead age lead agency
leader
so that's that'll be the people I'll
start with that
oh you can plan for how you're gonna
validate their responses from those and
I asked this because I've asked question
people which in surveys which I later
discovered they had no idea what the
answer she was sometimes they answer
what the population of your catchment
area etc so so I wonder how and in fact
the survey that Joan and I did a long
time ago buddy asked people in perhaps
physician order entry and we got to put
the answers from losing organization so
do you have a plan validate that replies
or how you're going to know whether you
need you that is one of the rules that
the that the follow-up interviews will
will have um if I start to get the sense
that we're really going in the wrong
direction with a couple of these
interviews where I'm incorporating the
results of that state's specific survey
results and asking about them then I'm
gonna have to back up I'm gonna have to
back up and when I do that if they were
grossly misunderstood if a subset of
questions were misunderstood I would
probably not be able to use that data
for and hopefully and other questions
would be well enough understood that I
can make something useful conclusions
that I could if they were all
misunderstood and they think I would
probably focus mostly healthy interviews
because I can actually ask people what
they think and get a sense of their
understanding follow-up to that question
is there not a validation process in
place or those items prior to sending
out that shake out yes just like I'm
going to do the first round of
developing the qualitative interview
guide with the Oregon state leaders I'm
currently in the process of validating
the questionnaire itself with Oregon
folks I've run it across a lot of desks
here in HSE you but I think it's most
important to get it in the hands of the
people that are closer to the target
population to get a sense of how the
tone comes across and misunderstandings
of terms and things like that but thank
you for bringing that up that's
absolutely part of the plan